at times medicine can be miraculous and
at other times it could stump us
completely that's what we're watching
today huge thank you to thrive market
for sponsoring this video
for most of his adult life Tim has
sounded like this
Tim spoke normally until 1978 when a
brutal incident robbed him of his voice
riding to a fire training seminar he
takes an Old Logging trip he has no way
of knowing that someone has maliciously
strung a cable across the road to stop
bikers dead oh my God why would you do
that that's terrible that's like
decapitation style Tim barely survived
the accident he eventually recovered
from his injuries but his larynx had
been crushed by the cable and was
irreparable for 20 frustrating years
Tim's only option was to speak through
the electronic voice box until a 1998
news story led him to Dr Marshall strong
a larynx specialist at the Cleveland
Clinic Foundation larynx is the voice
box pharynx is the throat for years Dr
strome had been working to perfect a
human larynx transplant and Tim heidler
was a perfect candidate in transplant
surgery the biggest danger is the donor
organ itself the recipient's immune
system naturally attacks it as a foreign
Invader a lot of times you're going to
have to take medications in order to
weaken your own body's natural response
against this organ doctors use drugs to
suppress the recipient's immune system
this can cause even the smallest
infection to become fatal and it also
creates a problem lifelong for many of
these patients with their
immunocompromised to viruses that maybe
you and I wouldn't be so concerned about
but those people who need to take extra
steps to be careful and also when you're
making a transplant like this for the
vocal cords you gotta be able to think
about the vascular connections which is
the blood supply but also neurologic
connections because you got to be able
to fire those muscles in addition to
supply them with blood flow Tim has
survived the surgery after an anxious
two and a half days doctors ask their
patient to speak okay one more breath
now the high mom
wow Jim heidler using a transplanted
larynx speaks for the first time you got
to be very careful here because the
vibrations can tear open the sutures as
well but you also don't want so much
scar tissue to form that you lose
Mobility to allow access to his new
larynx in case of complications doctors
decide to keep his trachea open in order
to speak it has to cover the hole to
force air through the transplanted
larynx I don't sound like the donor
because we have audio tapes of him and
he was a very large man he had a real
low voice well because that's
differences in spacing differences in
muscle tension you're not going to have
the one to one the same voice it's not
literally a voice box what makes us
sound the way we do
uh is the shape of our mouth
the amount of space that we have on our
head to resonate which is why our voice
boxes can be very different in terms of
Dimension sometimes I actually have had
this done for myself when I was
diagnosed with LPR laryngopharyngeal
reflux but it's an incredibly overlooked
diagnosis for people who are having
mucus in the back of their throat a
chronic cough maybe even a sore throat
that's worse in the mornings upon waking
even voice box changes but lately I've
been catching into my patients because
I'm more aware of it and successfully
treating those symptoms you can notice
when you run the [ __ ] way up
he has pitch he has inflection
wow is it totally normal speaking voice
yeah it is it's amazing this doctor is
like not taking any credit for this
pretty amazing like dude you did this
it's amazing you guys came together you
waited for the right donor that's
perfect back to the show in just a
second but first let me tell you about
Thrive Market an online Marketplace that
makes healthy living easy for everyone
with Thrive Market you'll save on every
single order of the highest quality
organic and sustainable products if you
find a lower price somewhere else
they'll match it it's not just groceries
like these cashews either but Home
Products beauty products even pet
products for bear I love that when
browsing the website you can organize it
based on the diet or values that are
important to you non-GMO fair trade
certified vegan keto gluten-free
whatever you need it's there something
I've enjoyed recently was looking for
products with the Thrive cash badge in
the bottom left-hand Corner whenever you
see this you can expect to earn Thrive
cash back for that product purchase
which means that you could spend more on
cash issues I swear they're that good
choose whatever membership that fits
your lifestyle one month 12 month
packages for me the 12-month package at
just five dollars a month is really the
reasonable choice and that's the one
that I recommend to my friends and
family even better you'll make your
annual 60 membership back in savings and
if you don't Thrive Market will credit
you with a difference join Thrive market
today and you'll get 30 off your first
order and a free gift worth up to sixty
dollars all you have to do is visit the
link down below thrivemarket.com Dr Mike
remember doctor is spelled out okay
let's get back to the show Mickey
Freeman is 40 years old but is trapped
in the body of a 10 year old
he's aging the equivalent of just one
year in every four aging or developing
because those are two different talking
points aging is almost like a Benjamin
Button situation where you're aging
backwards but here he seems to be
developing slowly based on the image
that I'm seeing here Nikki was born
blind and was close to death for his
first few months I wonder if it has
something to do with a an infection from
the birth at the age of 19 he was the
same size as his five-year-old sister he
only reached puberty as he approached 30
and as his younger siblings grew at a
normal rate he continued to weigh just
44 pounds the size of an average 10 year
old they're judging Age based on size
and that's not something we typically do
we can give age ranges size ranges for
ages but that's not the only sign of
development or aging what I'm curious
about are hormonal levels and if there
is any scans that have been conducted
full body mostly in the brain to see if
there is anything in the pituitary gland
anything related to growth hormone maybe
even the thyroid gland or a condition
where you have like a multiple endocrine
neoplasia situation where you have
multiple types of tumors in the
endocrine or hormonal system local
doctors have no clue as to what caused
Nikki's condition and no idea what his
future holds and because he doesn't
speak and can cannot see to read and
write doctors have no real way to gauge
his mental ability I mean I feel like
we're missing something here about
genetic testing scanning I know they're
not aware of what's going on but I feel
like I would at least want the next
steps taken to try and figure out what
is going on as the mother you think that
it is your fault
I do accuse myself of causing Nikki's
problem of course that's uh that's
always a feeling that can come into our
minds and irrational thoughts are part
of being human and part of battling the
feelings that come with those thoughts
is trying to speak back to those
thoughts and seeing how much truth is in
there usually this is best done through
journaling will you write down the
thoughts like I caused my son to be this
way and then you have to write down if
this is true or not and being as
rational and not emotional as possible
when you do that by writing you're going
to be more objective and as a result you
might be able to take away some of the
power of those thoughts where you still
might feel sad and all the negative
thoughts that might come your way but
they won't drag you down as deeply as
they would had you not done this process
what we're going to do is to run some
genetic tests and run some laboratory
tests and hopefully we'll be able to
determine the general cause of this
condition these are the words Kayleen
has been waiting decades to hear but to
fully understand Nikki's condition he
will also need an MRI scan yeah
something he's never had done before and
he has to lay incredibly still because
any kind of movement MRI will create an
unusable image the MRI suggests Nikki's
brain was damaged in the early months of
pregnancy which would account for his
lack of development and would also
explain his blindness I think it's an
infection
torch infection the examination of
Nikki's chromosomes didn't show anything
except a normal male
there was nothing genetically there that
would account for his condition it's at
least a relief to know this has no
genetic basis so your other children
probably don't have any cause to worry
that is the purpose of genetic testing a
lot of times folks are running to get
genetic testing for the fun of it or
just to find out and it's very dangerous
because you can get some information
that you can't adequately act upon and
in times you might even get information
that you'll act upon in a negative way
what do you do with information to find
out that you have a low risk for
developing diabetes do you start eating
more sugar after 40 years kaleen has the
answers she so desperately wanted after
Dr Walker explained everything to us
Nikki got off my lap
oh I went over to Dr Walker and now we
know what it's sweet I didn't expect
that I know so Alex just opened up the
door and his eyes were popping out of
his head and his hot and he didn't have
his top on and his whole top half was
just purple right away my mind goes to
something related to the thyroid hormone
because of exophthalmos commonly
associated with thyroid disease he
didn't really know if I was there or not
he was like going unconscious I didn't
know what this was you know for me he
had the flu no no that's not a flu
that's some kind of shock that a
person's going into when the blood
pressure is falling so rapidly you're
not getting enough circulation to vital
organs you start dying ambulance
emergency tell me exactly what's
happened my husband's body is full of
rat it's just rash it just looks the
same he's had the worst work headache
for like two or three days like
equipping headaches whenever we hear
worse headache of our life we think
Thunderclap headache and right away we
start getting Imaging yeah and he can't
um and it's just oh it's just blood's
coming out I used to take Kenny to take
I wouldn't bring up the rash first
because what's going to happen is
they're right away gonna think okay
non-serious emergency but if you open
with this the worst headache of a
person's life and they're urinating and
it's just exploding with blood that
changes the triage situation quickly
this is why as a medical professional
you have a little bit more success when
going through the traditional medical
system that you understand the things to
flag early on in order to get the right
attention when we got into the ambulance
and they sort of get in some penicillin
I was thinking yeah God is going to be
okay now it's you know he's in safe
hands now until you're in the hospital
you're not in safe hands Alex's flu-like
symptoms were caused by a common
bacteria normally found harmlessly on
the surface of the skin strep in an
extraordinarily rare case
streptococcal strand a or toxic shock
syndrome had entered Alex's body and was
attacking it traditionally when you hear
in media toxic shock syndrome you're
thinking of staph infection usually
associated with tampon use but this is
group a strep toxic shock syndrome which
is different the mortality rate and the
idea that you die is much higher the
radar which you die everything was dying
all his toes were dying all his
fingertips were dying all his ear lobes
his nose we don't know why it happens in
some people usually we think it's
because of a cut that the bacteria gets
in and then if they have a weaker immune
system for whatever reason they get this
really bad infection with the group a
strep but what's actually happening is
the group a strep bacteria form super
antigens which cause an overreaction of
your immune system if you will where
they create massive inflammation massive
cytokine release and as a result of
damage is all your tissues like across
your whole body there's been some
controversy about removing that tissue
perhaps maybe doing a watchful waiting
period when you're giving the
antibiotics and seeing if the person can
recover over nine months Alex undergoes
11 major operations to stabilize his
body today Alex is ready for the first
operation on his mouth the family hope
it will help rebuild his face but it
will be the first in a series of
operations that could last over two
years I wonder if it's the mouth the
tongue and the vocal cords that are
impacted here because I haven't heard
him speak yet there's some to see his
father like that is quite scary the same
looking like a completely different
person if you're not careful with the
way that you describe this to your child
you can create a long-term health
anxiety and a phobia of germs and that
could become problematic for a whole set
of reasons because in many of these
instances you can't protect yourself
from this this can just happen like
imagine every little cut you've ever had
have you taken proper care of it to the
nth degree no it's impossible and as a
result like certain things are outside
of our control but explaining that to a
child is not the easiest thing Alex is
now being looked after by a carer at
home while he continues his
Rehabilitation and surgery on his mouth
having been given prosthetic arms for
the first time Alex will attempt to
learn basic tasks again
I will pick that I'll pick that bit up
first pick that bit up first and then I
hope see wrong way up that way up and
then do that and just try picking that
up with your with your hook
foreign
it's like learning to walk all over
again basically what happens is you're
retraining your nerves and your muscles
to fire in a new way by seeing feedback
what's happening to the hook and trying
to pair that with the different
neurologic signals that you're sending
to new muscles the cost of it all told
with prosthetics is about 24 and a half
thousand pounds well that money is is
worth every penny for it now as the
times going by I see something new
happen every week I see him now open up
a fridge I see him now for himself a
drink of squash all of this is attitude
of mind and life
if you want your life you will go out
and get it it also helps that he has a
really strong support system with his
family that's there for him that's
caring for him that's allowing him
Transportation having the funds to buy
that bicycle you know all those things
are really important and not everyone
has access to them click here to find
out what clothes are bad for your health
and huge thanks again to thrive market
for sponsoring this video join Thrive
market today and get 30 off your first
order and a free gift worth up to sixty
dollars use my link to get started and
as always stay happy and healthy
foreign